[Music]
hello this is mario aquino and you're
watching another episode of strange loop
chats with me today is hillel wayne
before we get started i'd like to say a
few things about strange loot this year
which is going to run in st louis from
thursday september 30th through saturday
october the second
tickets for in-person and virtual
attendance are available through the
website
in addition to strange loop conference
and workshops tickets are also available
for tla plus conference
which is being held at st louis union
station alongside the strange loop
workshops on thursday september 30th
for more information please visit the
strangeloop.com
with that out of the way let me
introduce hello wayne
for anyone not familiar with him or with
tla plus
let me say that hillel spoke at strange
loop in 2017 where he gave a talk titled
tackling concurrency bugs with tla plus
viewers can watch that talk on this
youtube channel
hello thank you for sitting with me for
this interview pleasure to be here how
can i help you
for anyone not familiar with you tla
plus can you
give us kind of a summary what is tele
tla plus so let's actually start with a
bit of the bigger picture first okay
software correctness we need to be able
to write software that we want to be
able to write it quickly we want to be
able to write cheaply we want to be able
to write it that is correct right
generally there are multiple different
kinds of books the most common kinds of
bugs are what we might call
implementation details where you are
essentially writing something you mess
something up you put something in the
wrong place you're coding something and
you make a small mistake
those are the things that we try to
catch with our type systems our code
review our testing etc i'm sure you're
familiar with all of that
now there's another class of bugs
broadly that we can think of as design
bugs where you are implementing
something correctly but the thing you're
implementing
doesn't do what you want it to do
maybe it fundamentally has a race
condition just built into the core
essence there or maybe it doesn't
actually satisfy your requirements in
all cases or maybe there is one
execution which causes to shut down all
servers and you can't really say that
that's a bug because it's actually part
of the implementation it's part of the
features
so these are the bugs that are a lot
rare but they're also the ones that are
much more dangerous they tend to be
harder to detect they tend to blow up
much more nastily in production and
fixing them tends to take a lot more
time because you have to fundamentally
redesign your system
the problem with trying to solve these
things with like tests and types and
checking and such is that those all work
on the code level they work on an
existing implementation and these are
issues you want to find before you have
the implementation so you don't spend
weeks and weeks implementing the wrong
thing
this leads to a class of tools we call
formal specification languages which are
languages you can use to express
abstract models of the system and catch
these design bugs before you have to
start coding them
qla plus is one of the tools in this and
right now rapidly becoming the most
popular one due to accessibility and its
power
it was sort of catapulted to the main
stage by amazon web services when they
published a paper about how they found
critical bugs in s3 and dynamodb using
this bugs that passed
all their current correct error
correction systems and only took them
like a few weeks like a weekend in one
case of practice defined
that sort of got a lot more people into
it including me i used a small um
education startup where it probably
saved us months and tens or not hundreds
of thousands of dollars and that got me
excited to start talking about it more
publicly
the approach that tla plus takes for
um
doing i guess specification testing is
through expressing specifications in
the language of tla plus yes one way to
sort of think about that is that imagine
you're trying to implement i don't know
like
querying a database right at the really
really high level is just data's here it
is now in this value
at the actual implementation level you
have all of your like classes you have
your structures you have this entire
control flow you have audits you have
error checking you have probably a
logging in there somewhere you probably
have some kind of dependency injection
so you can swap it in out different
kinds of database and so what could be
hundreds of thousands of lines of
implementation code can at the really
high abstract level be one or two lines
of modeling code that actually sounds
really remarkable um i guess i would ask
how is it that
things that are i guess components of
distributed systems can be represented
with such little amount of modeling code
because fundamentally the idea here is
that we're looking at the design we're
looking at sort of trying to find these
these less common but much more critical
issues that exist at a much higher more
fundamental level of the system so we
can essentially abstract away all these
implementation details that stuff that's
necessary to make the system work on
computers but isn't really part of our
abstract machine our essential machine
as you might think of it
are there any uh kind of formal
specification languages that tla either
builds on or relies on or changes or
improves upon
um yes a little bit about the history of
like this entire space um there's a few
different branches that mostly started
vienne's development method of ibm and i
believe the late 1960s and then there
were sort of some offshoots of that um
primarily zed there was a central branch
called linear temporal logic which by
which was basically designed to
model essentially create a mathematical
representation of how things can change
and then essentially tla plus is
a synthesis of one branch of temporal
logic called temporal logic of actions
with um
ideas from
zed and a few other places i believe
so
time is a component of the specification
uh i guess the focus of the modeling
that you can do with the specification
language yeah the way we sort of think
about systems is
that we have all the things the system
can do it could say send a message or it
could drop a message or could the cue
could be reordering the messages or
something could receive a message
and then every possible execution of
those actions every possible like
sequence of states that the system go
through is called the behavior
then there is exist the set of all
possible behaviors the system can do
and what we want to guarantee using
these languages by expecting the
properties is that every single possible
behavior satisfies our high level
requirements
yeah there are other different there are
other different like models of like how
we specify and like how we represent
miles of systems this is the
tla plus way which tends to be very good
if you have to deal with any kind of
concurrency or distributing systems it's
less good for other things and it's
really a matter of choosing what your
problem domain is
can you kind of give
a an example of the kind of flaw that's
i guess maybe behavior-oriented that tla
plus would be able to catch in a
distributed system
so in the um in the tackling sorry bugs
at tla plus talk i gave it strange
loophole i gave some examples of how we
used it at my um old workplace
and one of the examples was what's
called the batch installer where we
essentially had to be moving a lot of
resources across a lot of different um
ipads
um essentially like app app resources
that we had a finite number of but we
were working through a system where
we moved them through by large um
batch apis
but this um
third-party system we had to work
through was both
eventually consistent and non-item
potent so if we essentially sent a
message saying do this it would be a
while before the physical world
reflected that reality and all before
their system reflect that reality and
also
by non-idapode it mean that if like we
were in that space where we said hey do
this and we said hey do this again it
would trigger a memory leak
if we were lucky with trigger memory
leak it could do other much worse things
so we had to build a system that
guaranteed all resources were eventually
in the right places
while also guaranteeing that we never
sent an um a request that would trigger
a memory leak by being non-item potent
given that there was delay between when
the real world
reflected what their system was and what
their system was telling us
i see yeah so a lot of places this can
go wrong and um a couple of the sprints
before we started using formal modeling
did have major issues where in specific
circumstances it could either break item
potency or break the requirement and a
resource would just be left on the table
um but we were able to use tla plus to
essentially create a model the system
that
the first model ended up having like a
19 step error trace where these 90
things would go wrong we would
like enter this loop where something
would just not get moved around and then
we could make a fix on that and then the
fix would turn out like have a different
issue so we'd rethink like the design
and eventually we were able to find a
design after like a couple of days of
modeling that guaranteed all the
properties we needed it also gave us
enough insight into what we need to do
that actually building the system ended
up taking like a couple weeks faster
than we expected
so um
considering what you were just
describing can you i guess a little bit
about where
dla plus fits in a development cycle
yeah so there's a few different ways
people use it this is actually more
interesting question because
given that this kind of floral
association tool sort of doesn't really
have any analogs in mainstream
development it's it's like a very large
field there's a lot of school ideas in
it but they're not like very common
tools
and because they solve an issue that
really isn't solved by anything else
when people sort of do start using these
tools they end up using them in a lot of
different ways that they might not
necessarily be the best use that may not
be the best tools to do that but because
there's nothing else out there
they're best creatively misused if that
makes sense
fundamentally there's a couple places
that are considered the proper place to
use them so for example um before you
start like writing a large amount of
code you model out the system you're
going to build it's also often used when
you're trying to refactor existing code
or like finding a bug where you create a
model the system to sort of figure out
better where the bug is
and then make the changes you expect
make sure that doesn't reintroduce a
different bug
that said because these tools can be
something that nobody really otherwise
has access to people end up using them
in a lot of different ways sort of
pushing glimpse of how they can use them
for example one of the earliest like
creative misuses i found was on
documenting things where you'd
essentially take a system and write an
executable documentation of the entire
system and show how making changes would
cause different impacts i've also seen
it used for people doing optimization
where they proven optimization would not
like introduce new bugs and have
identical behavior before actually like
implementing that optimization i've seen
people use it as a constraint solver or
as like a model space like generator
where they essentially use it to just
build out a state space and sort of see
what the state space looks like
so there's a lot of different ways you
can use it but the ways that the
majority people use it are either
are basically before you start
implementation
you did the describe uh the use of tla
plus
in
i guess a setting once either once you
have a
a working system or
maybe some way into the development
cycle for a system yeah i i remember
either from a talk that you've given or
maybe from your book how the
specifications that are expressed with
tla plus are completely separate from
the application
code itself it's just a completely
different thing and it doesn't it's not
meant to drive the application right
it's just meant to represent states that
the system can be in
given a model that describes how the
system's behaviors work right so i guess
one question i have is
how is it that teams that use tla plus
can try to keep the models that they
use to specify a system and the system
itself how do those things remain in
sync
when you have a working system
either when you have a working system
that tla plus was used to sort of design
the behaviors of or
when you have a working system and
you're sort of starting from scratch but
you get the model specification and the
application itself sort of in sync but
over time the system changes and grows
how do those things
like what are the ways that people try
to keep those things in sync code review
lots lots of code review
okay more less facilities than that that
is one of the core limitations of these
kinds of tools is that there's no easy
way to connect them to the code this is
often intentional it gives you more
flexibility and makes these tools much
easier to use and it's generally better
to get people using a tool that is
say
ten percent of the effort but only fifty
percent of the effectiveness first one
gets a hot that's like a 100 times the
effort and twice the effectiveness kind
of thing that said there are techniques
that people do use
one of the common ones that i've seen
and i've done myself is what's called um
i'm not sure if there's actually a
proper term for this but i sort of think
of it as trace testing so what you can
do is create your model right and the
model 10 essentially creates a state
space right of like everything that can
happen in the system and then what you
can do is you can
turn that into say a json stream of
actions and create what's called an
orchestrator on your code that reason is
json
and
makes the corresponding moves in your
system say it sees okay so this writer
will do this thing so we all send now a
message this writer and have it make
this like operation
then essentially what happens is you
then check that what the system does it
sorry what your code does matches what
the
abstract ta plus model does modulo like
translation between the data layers um
i've seen this actually used really
really effectively at some places the
main downside is that you kind of have
to hand roll
for the particular system you're working
on so we can't make any general
third-party libraries or at least nobody
has
yeah i guess figuring out a way for
the specification to either drive system
level tests or to use the specification
to confirm that the system behaves as
the model expects it to i feel like
those things would be like having some
some approach for tackling those
problems would help teams use the tool
in a way so that there's not a lot of
divergence right between the two right i
should emphasize though that while
divergence um can happen it's also going
to be solved at the human level with
like better processes and more
fundamentally i think it is important to
note that
while this isn't like well this would i
take like what we can do with stuff to
the next level what we can do currently
even with like code inspect diverging is
still much much much more valuable than
we can do without it
it would make it it would make a good
thing great it wouldn't make an
unacceptable thing acceptable if that
makes sense
yeah
so
as i've been thinking about tla plus
like one of the things that occurred to
me was
whether tla plus is either like a
proofer or a compiler for state machines
that represent distributed systems would
you say that that's a fair analogy um i
would not so
the first thing i want to mention here
is that there is actually a language
that sort of you write specifications
and it compiles them to actual state
machine code the most famous in this
category is actually um p as in ps and
pop-up by microsoft research
which essentially creates c-sharp code
based on abstract state machine
specifications
tla plus itself is just essentially a
notation for describing systems
then we have model checkers or proof
systems that then
take those models of the system and
verify that they have properties so i
guess
the the main the main like thing i
actually want to relate it to is um z3
but that's probably not very useful
either because that's also like a tool
in this space so i guess maybe the best
way to describe it would essentially be
like
a configuration language that generates
a test suite almost
but that's like honestly i it's honestly
kind of hard to come up with good
analogies here because this is like a
tool that like does something we don't
really do otherwise so like all the
analogies in some way end up breaking
down a bit
yeah that's that's not uncommon right
where you've got analogies that are
leaky in one way or another to try to
just communicate yeah an idea especially
one that's sort of novel and unlike
other things too
where is it that folks can learn more
about tla plus
so
first of all if you are coming to
strange loop we still have like space
open for a ti plus conference which
happens the day before so there are
essentially three resources actually
before i did um the strange sleep talk i
was so excited about this that i wrote
an online documentation
learntla.com that one i was updating
from about like 2017 to 2018. i'm
currently a little bit unsatisfied with
it and both but i haven't yet updated
because afterwards i got a book deal to
write
practical tla plus and i think this is
currently the best introduction to tla
plus a lot of pedagogy went into it it
is full of practical examples of how to
um
write um basically how to write specs
how to actually apply to business
problems how to use it for like modeling
requirements or distributed systems or
data structures et cetera
i currently i think that's the strongest
one i don't think it'll be the strongest
as a 2022 because i'm going to take the
stuff i learned in the past four years
to like completely revamp learn tla plus
i'm scheduled to start doing that am i
like planner starting 2022.
um and then finally if you want to sort
of go to the source and like learn the
canonical text to like learn
fundamentally what's going on versus
something more focused on getting you
applying it there are specifying systems
by leslie lamport
um this is actually free too if you um
download the tla plus toolbox it is
included as a free pdf
and it's a little bit more advanced and
i think requires a bit more like
mathematical like comfort with
mathematical ability
um and approaches it sort of in a bit of
a different way but it also like is the
reference text that people use to like
understand how the system works and like
how to resolve certain questions
so uh hello i want to thank you for
sitting with me for this interview it's
been really enjoyable talking to you for
anyone watching this video as i
mentioned at the beginning if you're
interested in strange loop conference
tickets are available for both in-person
and virtual attendance
workshop day for the conference is going
to be thursday september 30th that's the
same day as the tla plus conference and
i would like to point and i would like
to point out that if you're not going to
the tla plus conference paul swanson is
going to have a really cool um workshop
on busy data which is essentially like
vim for spreadsheets it is an extremely
cool piece of technology you should
definitely check it out
thank you for watching hello thanks
again for sitting for the interview
thank you for having me
[Music]
you